Sahiz Dalke ist mein Name und auf dieser Station bin ich als Assistenzastätich und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen, wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind.
Ja, bin ich.
Und ich werde zunächst einige allgemeine Fragen stellen, danach werde ich direkt zu Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Dann, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Annette Bischoff.
Annette Bischoff.
Am Ende gibt es Peh und Eff.
Oder können Sie bitte noch mal langsam bestellen?
Ja, ich kann wuchtern.
Annette A N N E T T E.
Annette ist der Vorname.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Und Bischoff B I S C H O F.
Frau Bischoff.
Ja.
Und wie alt sind Sie und wann wurden Sie geboren?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt und geboren bin ich am 15. Mai 1971.
Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie zu seid?
Ich bin 1,67 m groß.
Und wiege 64 kg?
60 kg.
Okay Frau Bischoff, was führt Sie zu uns heute? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe so seit ca. ungefähr 2 Tagen habe ich Schmerzen.
Im Bereich der Schulter, auf der linken Seite.
Und die Strahlen in den Arm aus, in den linken Arm bis in die Hand.
Linken Arm bis in die Hand haben Sie auch eine Ausstrahlung.
Okay, und sind die Schmerzen flüssig aufgetreten?
Nein, langsam.
Gibt es auch bestimmte Ausslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Ach, ich habe vor 2 Tagen eine Gymnastik gemacht, die habe ich vorher so noch nicht gemacht.
Weil ich immer so oben im Schulternackenbereich Verspannungen habe.
Aber ich arbeite auch stark körperlich.
Ich bin in einem Paketlager für Pakete, muss ich Pakete stapeln.
Und die sind teilweise ziemlich schwer, die wiegen teilweise 25 kg.
Und das ist ziemlich anstrengend.
Haben Sie etwas Schweres gehoben?
Ja, das muss ich jeden Tag.
Ich muss jeden Tag schwer heben.
Dann in der Vergangenheit hatten Sie auch solche Schmerzen?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nicht gehabt, dass die in den Arm ausstrahlen und in die Hand.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen? Leichte, mittelstark oder unverträglich?
Was würden Sie sagen?
Inzwischen finde ich die Schmerzen ziemlich stark.
Und sind die Schmerzen immer da oder manchmal lassen die Schmerzen nach?
Eigentlich sind die Schmerzen immer da.
Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel den Kopf drehe, besonders wenn ich den Kopf nach rechts drehe,
dann verstärkt sich der Schmerz.
Oder wenn ich huste oder niesen muss, verstärkt sich der Schmerz auch.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe nicht Fieber.
Und haben Sie vielleicht auf den Burustschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Keine Burustschmerzen.
Und gibt es auch an den linken Arm Taubweißgefühl, am Eisenlauf oder Kribbeln?
Ich habe ein bisschen Taubweißgefühl im Arm,
an bestimmten Stellen hier auf der Haut.
Nicht am ganzen Arm, aber an bestimmten Stellen.
Und auch so ein bisschen Kribbeln.
Wann genau diese Gefühle?
Mit den Finger, Daumen oder…
Das ist mehr Daumen und etwas Zeigefinger.
Ah, okay.
Gibt es auch Bewegungsanschränkungen?
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen?
Also, wenn ich den Hals versuche zu bewegen,
was ich sagte, wenn ich je nach rechts ein bisschen drehe,
dann verstärkt sich der Schmerz im Arm.
Und ich kann den Hals nicht gut bewegen.
Das traue ich mich nicht.
Und auch nicht sehr stark den Arm bewegen.
Wenn ich den Arm so über die Schulter hochhebe,
das ist nicht gut.
Das mache ich nicht.
Ich konnte auch heute nicht arbeiten.
Okay, ich kann auch für Sie ein Kranz schreiben.
Können Sie vielleicht den Kopf an den Brust neigen?
Haben Sie auch damit Bewegungsanschränkungen?
Ja, kann ich auch nicht so gut.
Geht auch nicht so gut.
Aber vorher besser.
War Ihnen übel oder haben Sie schon erbrochen?
Nein.
Und Frau Wischloff, ich möchte mich auch
über die Körperfunktion informieren.
Also, gibt es auch Nachtauschweiß, Schweißausbrücke?
Nein, Nachtschweiß habe ich nicht.
Okay, und gibt es Probleme beim Stuhlkrank
oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Und wie schlafen Sie?
Gibt es auch damit Probleme einzuschlafen
oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, seit zwei Nächten kann ich nicht so gut schlafen,
seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe.
Da kann ich auch nicht gut liegen.
Da muss ich mich immer verändern in der Lage.
Die letzte Nacht habe ich im Sessel geschlafen.
Okay.
Das war noch am besten.
Sonst noch mal.
Und in letzter Zeit ist Ihnen auch
Herzrasen, Herzstolpernen oder Probleme
mit der Atmung aufgefallen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Probleme mit der Atmung oder so?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay, hatten Sie einen Unfall oder ein Schlagbekommen
oder Verletzung?
Nein.
Gibt es auch an dem linken Arm oder Naken
eine Abschulfung oder offene Wunden
oder Farbfährendierung?
Solche Dinge ist auch in den Aufgefahren.
Ich kann mich an Verletzungen nicht erinnern
oder eine Hautveränderung.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Sie haben auch keine Bauchschmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen habe ich auch nicht.
Super.
Frau Bischoff, ich würde gerne auch
auf die Vorerkrankungen
sowie die Operationen eingehen.
Gibt es bei Ihren Krankengesicht
die oder gründliche Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich habe Asthma,
aber leichtes Asthma.
Manchmal im Winter ist das schlimmer.
Ich habe Hausstaub,
Milben und Verträglichkeit.
Ich habe auch etwas Heuschnupfen.
Aber zurzeit ist das eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich nehme immer meinen Asthma Spray.
Ich mache zurzeit nur einmal pro Tag,
weil es mir ganz gut geht.
Es gibt aber manchmal Phasen,
da brauche ich zwei pro Tag.
Okay.
Und wissen Sie die Name der Spray?
Ja, das Mittel heißt
Sanastmül.
Sollte ich das Buch stabilieren?
Ja, es wäre besser für mich.
Das heißt, ich habe das hier auf den Zettel,
S-A-N-A-S-T-H-M
M-Y-L-Sanastmül.
Da sind so Kapseln in einem Apparat.
Da drücke ich drauf, da gibt es so einen Staub,
so einen Nebel.
Das muss ich einatmen.
Ja, sie tief einatmen wäre.
Und noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich war vor drei Wochen beim Auto
oder vier Wochen beim Orthopäden.
Da hatte ich auch eben so ein Halswirbelsäulenbeschwerden.
Und da hat er geröntcht.
Und da hat er gesagt, ja, ich habe Verschleiß
an der Halswirbelsäule.
Aber da hatte ich diese Schmerzen nicht,
die in den Arm austalten.
Das war da nicht.
Aber gegen diese Beschwerden
benutzt ein Sieg keine Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe das dann behandelt mit Wärme.
Rotlichtlampe und Wärme.
Und er hat mir beraten,
ich soll auch, wenn es geht, mal schwimmen gehen.
Im Wasser, kein Brust schwimmen,
sondern mehr so Rücken schwimmen.
Und das hat mir ganz gut getan.
Ja, das ist gut.
Sie haben gut gemacht.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich operiert.
Das war, da hatte ich Mandeloperation einmal.
Und einmal Blindamoperation.
Da war ich so 10, 11 Jahre alt.
Und dann habe ich noch 2 Operationen gehabt.
Bei den Geburten hatte ich Kaiserschnitte.
Dann verstehe ich, dass Sie 2 Kinder haben.
Ja.
Sind Sie ganz gesund?
Super.
Aber habe ich richtig verstanden,
im Arte her von 10 Mandeloperationen
in Blindgram-Operationen.
Und nehmen Sie auch neben den genannten Medikamente
noch andere Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Nur das Asthma-Mittel.
Reagieren Sie auch etwas allergisch?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Nur Heistapen, Milben, Begen.
Und Polen.
Frühblühe, also Gräser.
Das vertrage ich auch nicht sehr gut.
Dann habe ich auch Asthma.
Aber ich habe leider Bergissen.
Seit wann leiden Sie hier an Asthma?
Seit der Jugend schon.
Und Verträchtigkeiten?
Sind bei Ihnen bekannt?
Nein.
Super.
Ich würde gerne auch die
nähen Verwandtschaften-Krankheiten
eingehen.
Gibt es in Nähen Verwandtschaften wie Vater, Mutter
oder Schwester wichtig oder chronisch Erkrankungen?
Also,
die Mutter,
die ist 76 Jahre alt,
hat hohen Blutdruck und alt als Zucker.
Was bedeutet altes Zucker?
Alterszucker.
Sie hat das erst bis mit 60 Jahren
diagnostiziert, dass sie Zucker hat.
Vorher war das kein Problem.
Da hat man gesagt, das ist alterszucker.
Der Vater ist 76 Jahre alt.
Er hat vor 3 Jahren Prostatakrebs gehabt.
Er ist operiert worden.
Und dem Goethe ist aber ganz gut.
Er hat auch noch häufig erhöhte Harnsäure-Werte.
Er hatte auch schon 2-mal Gichtanfälle.
Da muss er irgendeine Medikamente nehmen.
Aber die kenne ich nicht.
Kein Problem.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Die Schwester ist 55 Jahre alt.
Bei der Schwester wurde die Gallenblase entfernt.
Sie hatte Gallensteine
und auch Beschwerdenkoliken.
Im Alter von 55?
Ja, ja.
Das war im Vorjahr.
Als ich 54 war, war das gemacht worden.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Mit meinem Mann?
Ja, die beiden Töchter und Kinder wohnen nicht mehr bei uns.
Okay.
Wir sind ganz gesund, haben gesagt.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin in der Logistik tätig.
Ich muss diese Pakete teilweise packen.
Ich muss sie teilweise packen.
Ich muss sie stapeln.
Das ist sehr anstrengend.
Gibt es auf der Arbeit oder in der Familie
Sträße, die Sie belasten?
Nein.
Ganz gut.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für mich gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich frage mich, was kann das sein?
Das macht mir schon Sorgen.
Was habe ich noch nie gehabt?
Ich perste Ihre Angst.
Aber Sie haben schon seit ungefähr 1 Monat
an solche Schmerzen leiden.
Damals wurde bei Ihnen auch ein Magnetikversennersthormografie
oder Spinkenthormografie durchgeführt.
Nein, das wurde nur gereinigt.
Die Schmerzen waren damals anders.
Das ist etwas, die spuralen in den Arm aus.
Die habe ich erst seit 2 Tagen.
Vor einigen Monaten, wo ich beim Orthopäden war,
hatte ich mir die Schmerzen in der Mitte im Rücken.
Ein bisschen etwas anders ist das.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Sie werden das jetzt noch nicht mehr verabredet.
Ich habe das jetzt noch nicht mehr verabredet.
Aber Sie werden das vielleicht und hoffe ich,
dass Sie das herausfinden.
Ja, nach der gegebenen Untersuchung können wir die Diagnose feststellen.
Aber tatsächlich, so seit die Diagnose zu sagen,
ist ein bisschen schwer.
Es sieht ein, wie Nerven, ein Klemmpunkt aus.
Das ist das, wie ich das sage,
die Schädigung zu Ihrer Bischofelden führen.
Gut, dann können wir das ausprobieren.
Jetzt werde ich erst mal untersucht von Ihnen.
Gleich werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
In jedem Fall brauchen wir auch einige Laborwerte.
Deswegen werde ich Ihnen bulletabieren.
Das ist das, was ich für die Diagnose habe.
Dann können wir entscheiden, wie wir weitergehen.
Wie gehen wir weiter vor?
Gut, das können wir so machen.
Danke.
Dann haben Sie jetzt ein bisschen Zeit.
Kollegen haben vielleicht noch Ergänzungsfragen.
Ich würde noch so zwei, drei Fragen stellen.
Aber vielleicht ein bisschen mehr.
Ich würde noch ein bisschen mehr fragen.
Eine Ergänzung, aber vielleicht sagen die Kollegen das.
Darf ich Fragen?
Bitte.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Zum Beispiel, wie Sie sich schmerzen,
wie Sie sich drücken schmerzen?
Okay, ja, eine wichtige Frage.
Der Schmerz ist mehr so dumpf.
Er ist nicht so brennend oder hell.
Er ist mehr dumpf und ziehend.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala?
Wobei 1 leichtes Schmerz, 10 am stärksten Schmerz entspricht.
Also ich würde sagen, in Ruhe ist der Schmerz bei 6.
Aber wenn ich irgendwie husten muss oder niesen muss
oder den Kopfversuch zu drehen, dann ist er mehr bei 7.
Haben Sie Brustverletzung oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Brustkorb würde ich sagen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ist Ihnen Schwellung, Röthung oder Überwärmung
an der Betroffenen Stelle aufgefallen?
Ich habe nicht gesehen.
Das hat der Kollege auch schon gefragt, glaube ich.
Also die Haut ist nicht verändert.
Okay, danke.
Darf ich fragen, Frau Bischoff?
Bitte.
Haben Sie Lehmungen in den Arm oder Finger bemerkt?
Ja, die Frage nach Kraftminderung.
Ja, ich habe den Eindruck, dass ich in der linken Hand
nicht so viel Kraft habe wie vorher.
Ich kann es bewegen, aber ich habe nicht so viel Kraft.
Ich habe nicht so viel Kraft wie ich vorher hatte.
Das hat sich verändert.
Welche Finger?
Besonders der Daumen und der Zeigefinger.
Da geht auch der Schmerz hauptsächlich rein.
Daumen und Zeigefinger.
Darf ich fragen?
Bitte.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie vor vier Wochen
ähnliche Beschwerden haben.
Könnten Sie bitte beschreiben, wie diese Schmerzen waren?
Vor drei, vier Wochen sind diese Schmerzen auch immer wieder vorher mal gewesen.
Die sind aber mehr hinten in der Wirbelsäule, am Rücken oben.
Während jetzt die Beschwerden mehr in der linken Schulter sind
und in den linken Arm gehen.
Das ist ein Unterschied.
Ich würde sonst sicher noch mal fragen,
mit Gewichtsverhalten.
Haben Sie Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit?
Ist das Gewicht konstant?
Das Gewicht ist konstant.
Da hat sich nichts verändert.
Dann vielleicht noch persönliche Risikofaktoren rauchen Sie?
Die Frage ist nicht gestellt worden.
Ich habe es schon versucht, mit Programmen aufzugeben.
Das kann ich leider nicht ablegen.
Alkohol trinke ich nicht.
Aber etwas rauchen.
Wie ist Ihr Drogenkonsum?
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie.
Ich habe noch nie.
Sind Sie in Wechseln?
Ja, ich war jetzt bei der Gynäkologin.
Auch weil meine Periode ist unregelmäßig geworden.
Die Gynäkologin sagt, ich wäre jetzt in den Wechseljahren.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen auch in der
Gynäkologin?
Ich versuche jedes Jahr oder alle 1,5 Jahre zu Frauenerzins zu gehen.
Herr Oberst, wenn Sie es seid, würde ich den neuen Patient vorstellen.
Frau Annette Bischoff, eine 54-jährige Patient,
stelle sich bei uns wegen seit 2 Tagen bestörenden und langsam aufgetretenen,
progliedienten, dumpfer und sichenden Schmerzen im linken Schulter vor.
Sie begleitet von einer Ausstrahlung in den linken Arm bis zur linken Hand.
Die Patienten in die gesamte linke Hand oder in bestimmte Areale der Hand?
Besonders in den Daumen und in den Seigefingern.
Die Patienten belichtete über eine Parästhesien,
sowie Hyperesthesien, auch an den Daumen und die Auseltermärwente,
dass die Schmerzen sich bei der Bewegung verstärken.
Bei welcher Bewegung besonders?
Bewegungs des Kopfes, z.B. zur Seite.
Sagen Sie da ruhig bei Rechtsrotation?
Rechtsrotation der HWS, oder des Kopfes.
Rechtsrotation, also in der Horizontalebene.
Nach der rechten Seite des Kopfes, oder nach der rechten Seite des Kopfes.
Sagen Sie ruhig Rechtsrotation, oder linksrotation.
Links wäre nach links, und das andere ist rechtsrotation.
Sie können aber auch sagen, bei Rotation nach rechts,
das ist vielleicht etwas klarer für Sie.
Ja, danke schön.
Und gibt es sonstige Sachen, wie der Schmerz sich verstärkt?
Die Schmerzen verstärken, sowie neben der Bewegung.
Denken Sie an Husten und Niesen?
Ach so, Husten und Niese.
Es besteht auch Schmerzverstärkung bei Husten und Niesen.
Die Schmerzen verstärken sich beim Husten und Niesen.
Und zudem teilt uns die Patienten.
Wie stark ist der Schmerz in der Skala?
In der Skala hat der Patient in Ruhe 6 von einem Skala von 1 bis 10.
Bei der Bewegung hat der Patient in der Schmerz 7.
Ruhe Schmerz bei 6, und durch Rotation, Bewegung oder Nies Schmerz,
Husten Schmerz bei 7.
Die Frage nach Unfall, Verletzungen,
sowie Wunde von der Patientin, Verneins.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf Insomni,
wegen aktuellen Beschwerden unauffällig.
Der Patient leidet seit der Jugend an Asthma, Brunchialitis,
und wird mit Sanasitmil.
Sanasmül.
Das ist ein schwieriges Wort.
Die Patientin hat ein allergisches Asthmabrunchiale.
Auf was für Substanzen?
Für Asthma und Hausstorpmilben.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Grundproblem,
weil das ganze Jahr über ist Hausstorpmilben.
Was können Sie mir noch berichten?
Ist die Patientin voroperiert?
Die Patientin wurde als Kind 2-mal operiert.
Eine von ihnen ist im Alter von 10.
Die andere war im Alter 11 Abhändektumie.
Tonselektumie und Abhändektumie.
Das waren die Operationen und sonstige operative Eingriffe.
2-mal hat die Patientin die kaisere Schnittin bekommen.
Kennen Sie den Fachbegriff für Kaiserschnitt?
Sagen Sie ruhig.
Eine Operation wurde durchgeführt.
Im Alter von 10 Jahren eine Tonselektumie, im Alter von 11 eine Abhändektumie.
Die Kinder sind 24 und 27.
2-mal die Geburt jeweils durch Sektion.
Das ist eine Einfass-Lektion.
Gibt es sonst noch etwas in der Vorgeschichte?
Denken Sie vielleicht noch an die Alzwöbelsäulen-Problematik der Patientin?
Sie war beim Facharzt?
Ja, der Patient hat eine...
Die Patientin?
Die Patientin ist wegen heißen wirelten Säule beschwerden
oder schmerzen einen Besuch von Facharzt.
Also beim Orthopäden.
Sie können ruhig sagen, die Patientin war wegen HWS-Beschwerden vor einigen Wochen
oder Monaten beim Orthopäden.
Das kann man sagen.
Damals wurde nur eine Röntgen-Untersuchung durchgeführt.
Und der Orthopäde stellte wahrscheinlich die Diagnose
wahrscheinlich degeneratives HWS-Syndrom.
Achso, ja.
Aber jetzt hat sich ja inzwischen die Beschwerdesymptomatik geändert.
Die Schmerzsymptomatik und die Lokalisation der Schmerzen.
Die Ausstraum hat sich geändert.
Gut.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familien-Vorgeschichte?
Ja.
Und der Vater der Patientin wurde im ATR 76 wegen Prostatokalsenum operiert
und die Operation hat gut verlauft.
Verlaufen, ja.
Verlaufen.
Und der Vater leidet auch unter Hyperhauensäurewerte im Blut.
Ja.
Hyperhauensäurewerte.
Sehr gut, ja.
Und was hat er gehabt?
Er hat schon zweimal...
Zweimal einen Gichtanfall.
Ja, Gichtanfall.
Kennen Sie da eventuell ein Fachbegriff,
das ist eine Artritis-Urika.
Artritis-Urika.
Okay.
Und die Mutter?
Ja, die Mutter ist 76 Jahre alt und leidet an arterielle Hyperatonie
und alt sehr wenig der Diabetes mellitus.
Ja, können Sie sagen Diabetes mellitus Typ 2?
Ja.
Ja, das wäre den erworbenen Diabetes mellitus.
Ja?
Ja.
Gut.
Und hat sie noch Geschwister?
Die Patientin hat eine Geschwister
und bei ihr wurde geilen Blasen Entfernung,
geilen Blasen Operation, Kohlesystikdomie durchgeführt.
Ja, wann war das?
Im Altjahr 1957.
Ja, vor einem Jahr, die Patientin ist ja etwas älter,
vor einem Jahr wurde bei der Schwester eine Kohlesystikdomie durchgeführt.
Okay.
Mehr müssen Sie gar nicht sagen dazu.
Ja, gibt es sonst Rikofaktoren, Alkohol, Rauchen, Drogen?
Ja, bei der Anamnese habe ich leider nicht darüber richtige Fragen gestattet,
aber dann habe ich später gelernt, der Patient raucht.
Die Patientin?
Die Patientin raucht fünf Zigaretten täglich seit, ich weiß nicht.
30 Jahre?
Seit 30 Jahren und Alkoholkonsum Ude Fereneins.
Sie können sagen, was das Nikotin angeht, es ist jetzt ja kein hoher Nikotinkonsum,
fünf Zigaretten, verglichen mit vielen anderen.
Sie können sagen, es besteht ein regelmäßiger Nikotinkonsum von fünf Zigaretten pro Tag über 30 Jahre.
Das kann man so ruhig sagen.
Also es ist etwas anders, als wenn jemand pro Tag eine ganze Schachtel raucht oder so.
Aber immerhin, es ist trotzdem ein regelmäßiger Nikotinkonsum.
Das ist so.
Okay, danke schön.
Ja.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Zunächst habe ich an Haals-Helbersolle Prolapsus gedacht,
aber es kann auch arterielle Hypertonie sein.
Warum arterielle Hypertonie?
Weil die Beschwerden der Patienten wie Narkenschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen
und die in der linken Arme Kribbons oder Paristise sprechen
für vielleicht arterielle Hypertonie.
Man muss bestimmt diese Krankheit ausschließen.
Okay.
Aber ich bin auch nicht sicher.
Wie erklären Sie sich, dass die Beschwerden zunehmen bei Bewegung, bei Kopfbewegung?
Bei der Hypertonie gibt es nicht solche Beschwerden, sie haben rechts.
Aber bei der Bewegung so nennen, dass ich messen kann,
eventuell für eine Haals-Helbersolle Prolapsus sprechen.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich schon sagen,
als erster Stelle würde ich ein Wurzelreizsyndrom,
eine Cervicobrachialgie, also HWS und Arm.
Prachialgie in welchem Segment, welches Segment kommt da in Betracht,
Daumen und Zeigefinger?
C5.
Ja, also ein oberes Segment.
Richtung Beinfinger wäre es eher C8, C7, 8.
C5.6 würde ich auch sagen, das spricht viel dafür.
Es sind diese Kribbelparistisien verbunden mit Kraftminderung.
Bei Hypertonie würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Kraftminderung denken.
Die Verstärkung bei Husten und Niesen des Schmerzes,
weil durch den Husten und Niesreiz wird ein Druck auf den Diskus
bzw. auf die Nervenstruktur ausgeübt.
Und das verstärkt auf den Schmerz danach per Refer.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich an ein C5.6-Syndrom,
vielleicht mit Diskusprolaps eben, wie das jetzt schon ist.
Ist ja eine neurologische Symptomatik.
Auf alle Fälle ist die Wurzel gereizt.
Die Wurzel, in dem Segment die Nervenwurzel.
Weiteres muss natürlich die weitere Diagnostik ergeben.
Ich würde sicherheitshalber natürlich auch eine coronare Herzerkrankung ausschließen.
Man ist da manchmal immer überrascht.
Vielleicht hat sie beides.
Es sind ja nicht immer gerade bei Frauen so klassische Schmerzen,
was coronare Herzerkrankung angeht.
Aber vorrangig würde ich schon eher an ein Symptomatikbereich der Bandscheibe
der Wurzelreizung denken bei der Patientin.
Das tatsächlich habe ich auch über Herzkrankheit gedacht.
Deswegen die Brust und Bauchschmerzen.
Ja klar.
Aber das muss ja nicht immer geklärt werden.
Sicherheitshalber natürlich ein gutes EKG machen.
Und das muss man auch immer wieder auf die Brust und Bauchschmerzen
abklären.
Ja gut, erstmal vielen Dank.
Haben Sie ruhig und systematisch gemacht.
Sie haben zwei, drei Dinge vergessen zu fragen.
Haben Sie da einen Bogen vor sich liegen, wo Sie abfragen?
Oder machen Sie das aus dem Gedächtnis?
Aus dem Gedächtnis machen wir bei der Prüfung.
Ich habe auch jetzt Säugermacht.
Deswegen habe ich die Genussmittelanahmen sehr
vergessen.
Gut, das ist jetzt nicht so das ganz Entscheidende in diesem Sinne.
Aber was noch mal wichtig ist, befragen Sie genau den Schmerz.
Fragen Sie die Patientin, können Sie mir den Schmerz beschreiben?
Wie ist der Schmerz?
Das haben wir gefragt.
Welchen Charakter hat der Schmerz?
Nicht das ein wichtiges Kriterium, in diesem Fall ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Er ist also nicht kein brennender Schmerz.
Wie vielleicht, eventuell haben Sie ja gefragt, mit Hautveränderung
vielleicht hat der Patientin auch eine Zosterneurologie.
Das sind dann mit unterbrennenden Schmerzen bei Berührung empfindlich
taktil und eventuell mit Effluorizenzen.
Es müssen aber nicht immer Effluorizenzen auf der Haut sein.
Es gibt leider auch ein herbst Zoster ohne Effluorizenzen.
Das ist dann ganz gemein.
Aber es ist eben vergleichsweise bei einer Patientin,
die 54 Jahre alt ist, noch relativ selten,
dass sie so eine Art von herbst Zoster haben.
Die sind oft etwas älter, die Patienten.
Aber in diesem Falle, sie beschrieb das ja, sie muss schwer heben.
Sie ist beruflich stark da gefährdet.
Die hatte schon eine Anamnese in der Halswirbelsäule.
Sie war bei einem Orthopäden.
Da waren die Schmerzen etwas anders.
Wahrscheinlich war die Diagnostik auch eher nicht so ganz gründlich
vielleicht beim Orthopäden, sondern es war dann schnell degenerativ.
Das ist halt leider so manchmal.
Ich würde jetzt, wie gesagt, sagen in erster Linie die Discos,
Vertracht auf Discos Prolapse und differential diagnostisch,
sicherlich muss man eine Kaka ausschließen,
eine andere Neuralgie, eventuell Neuropathie.
Das war die Frage mit Plexosyntomatik.
Das muss man natürlich dann differenzieren.
Aber in erster Linie so in die Richtung denken.
Gut, aber ich habe sie gut verstanden.
Sie können die Fachbegriffe in aller Regel sehr gut.
Denken Sie mal dran, bei Frauen ist es die Patientin, die Feminin.
Das wird aber ganz oft gemacht. Die Beobachtung habe ich.
Es ist dann ganz oft der Patient.
Versuchen Sie das zu unterscheiden.
Ja, ich mache immer mit meinen Kollegen Similas Fürnü.
Damals machen wir für einen Mann die Rolle spielen.
Deswegen mache ich solche Fälle.
Ja, das ist dann auch schwierig, besonders wenn ich Ihnen jetzt vorsitze.
Ich sage dann immer, ich bin eine Frau.
Bitte da noch, dass Sie das differenzieren.
Aber Sie kennen die meisten Fachbegriffe gut
oder Sie haben sich auch gut erschlossen.
Sie überlegen kurz und dann war das mit der Sektio-Weinordnung,
mit der Kölner Zistektomie.
Das war alles gut.
Haben Sie schon einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, nächste Woche, Mittwoch.
Ja, das schaffen Sie.
Das wird gut.
Wo machen Sie die Prüfung?
In Dresden.
Okay, gut.
Ich wünsche Ihnen dazu viel Erfolg.
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl, dass Sie das gut schaffen.
Danke schön.
Alles klar.
Dann würde ich jetzt sagen, sonst für die Gruppe,
wenn Sie wollen, sehen wir uns nächste Woche Donnerstag wieder.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Alles klar.
Herr Nebel Sieg, darf ich heute Frage stellen?
Können wir die Prüfung in Sachsen machen?
Können wir für die Patienten, die heutige Patientin,
in Vorstellung Arzt sprechen?
Können wir die Patientin hat Nackensteifigkeit sagen?
Hat diese Patientin Nackensteifigkeit?
Sie hat Schmerzen, sagt sie mehr in der Schulter links.
Dann strahlt das ein bisschen aus,
aber direkt in Nackensteifigkeit.
Sie denken so eine Nackensteifigkeit wie bei Menigitis?
Nein, nein.
Für diesen Fall habe ich nicht gedacht.
Aber der Arzt hat die Frau gefragt,
beugen Sie Ihre Kopfpfeuer?
Ja, etwas nach vorne.
Da hat die Patientin gesagt,
die hat die Nackensteifigkeit nicht gedacht.
Sie hat die Nackensteifigkeit nicht gedacht.
Sie hat die Patientin gesagt,
das geht nicht so gut.
Sie kann es noch vorne beugen, aber eingeschränkt.
Die Bewegung in den Bewegungsebenen
bei der Patientin wahrscheinlich,
bei der Untersuchung werden Sie das feststellen,
dass die Bewegung überall eingeschränkt ist.
Sie hat gesagt,
bei Rechtsrotationen verstärkt sich der Schmerz.
Wurzel gereizt wird. Vielleicht auch bei Vorbeuge oder in den Nacken, das muss dann natürlich die
Untersuchung erzeugen. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass man da von einer Nackenstärkigkeit
sprechen kann.
Die Nackenstärkigkeit ist starker Meningismus.
Meningismuszeichen. Das wäre, dass die, dass der, ne, die Nackenstärkigkeit völlig da ist.
Das sind Meningismuszeichen. Ja.
Gut.
Dankeschön.
Okay.